considera las sumas de riman por la
izquierda y por la derecha que se
aproximen al área debajo de la g de x
entre x2 y x igual a 8 entonces queremos
aproximar esta área azul que tenemos
aquí las aproximaciones son sobre
estimadas o subestimadas ok vamos a
considerar las sumas de riman por la
izquierda y por la derecha empecemos con
la izquierda solo voy a escribir
izquierda pero sabemos que estamos
hablando de la suma de riman por la
izquierda y como no nos dicen cuántas
subdivisiones hay que hacer para nuestra
aproximación eso lo decidimos nosotros
supongamos que haremos tres
subdivisiones y que vamos a hacer las
del mismo tamaño no tiene que ser así
pero vamos a dividirlo de esa manera
para la primera vamos de 2 a 4 después
de 4 a 6
y finalmente de 6 a 8 entonces si
hacemos la suma de riman por la
izquierda vamos a usar el lado izquierdo
de cada una de las subdivisiones para
poder encontrar la altura que queremos
para evaluar la función así que vamos a
concentrarnos en el lado izquierdo de
cada una de estas subdivisiones por lo
tanto para establecer la altura del
primer rectángulo aproximado usaremos g
de dos luego usaremos g de cuatro para
el siguiente rectángulo que sería este y
después usaremos g de seis para
representar la altura del tercer
rectángulo ok ahora así podemos ver
claramente que la suma de riman por la
izquierda es una sobreestimación porque
bueno porque podemos ver que el área que
tratamos de aproximar siempre está
contenida en estos rectángulos pero en
este caso los rectángulos tienen esta
área extra así que siempre serán más
grandes que las áreas que tratamos de
aproximar en general si tenemos una
función
disminuye estrictamente sobre el
intervalo que nos interesa si disminuye
todo el tiempo y usamos el lado
izquierdo de cada subdivisión para
aproximar el área vamos a tener una
sobreestimación porque del lado
izquierdo el valor de la función es más
grande que el valor de la función en
cualquier otro punto de la subdivisión
por eso es que para la disminución de la
función la suma de riman por la
izquierda será una sobreestimación ahora
pensemos en la suma de riman por la
derecha tal vez ya sepan que será lo
contrario pero vamos a visualizar si
continuamos con las mismas tres
subdivisiones pero ahora usamos el lado
derecho de cada una de ellas para
definir la altura para el primer
rectángulo la altura está definida por g
de 4a y está después para el segundo
será g de 6 ok y para el tercero será g
de 8 entonces voy a sombrear los
rectángulos para que se vea más claro de
qué rectángulos estamos hablando
esta es la suma de riman por la derecha
para aproximar el área miren aquí está
muy claro que será una subestimación
porque podemos ver que en cada uno de
estos intervalos la suma de riman o
mejor dicho el rectángulo que estamos
usando para la suma de riman por la
derecha es un subconjunto del área que
estamos tratando de estimar y no podemos
capturar esta área que tenemos aquí y
eso es porque esta es una función que
disminuye estrictamente por lo que si
usamos el lado derecho en cualquiera de
estas subdivisiones para definir la
altura el valor correcto de g será el
valor menor de g en esta subdivisión así
que será una altura menor a la que
podríamos decir que sería la altura
promedio del valor de la función sobre
el intervalo por lo tanto en esta
situación tenemos una subestimación
ahora si nuestra función fuera
aumentando estrictamente entonces esto
se intercambiaría claro hay muchas
funciones que puede que no aumenten o
disminuyan estrictamente y es
depende de la función pero incluso
muchas veces depende del tipo de
subdivisiones que elijamos para decidir
si tenemos una subestimación o una
sobreestimación con esto terminamos